bienvenue pour une nouvelle édition du
78 le journal sur TVfil 68 aujourd'hui
12 septembre dans l'actualité la
provvreté qui progresse nous verrons
avec Pascal Rodier le président du
Secours populaire dans les Yvelines
quelle est la situation un sondage
diffusé hier la teste en tout cas de
tiers des Français affirme connaître au
moins une personne parmi leur F ou leur
connaissance en situation précaire les
notaires la semaine prochaine seront
mobilisés dans la rue il dénoncent un
projet de réforme sans concertation qui
doit ouvrir notamment les actes de vente
à d'autres professions l'État entend
ainsi diminuer les frais pour les
particuliers et puis comme chaque
vendredi le point sur l'essentiel de la
semaine de l'ouverture du premier
Institut d'études politiques en France
depuis 20 ans c'est à Saint-Germain en
lait à la colère des mes contre
l'élargissement des
intercommunalités un chiffre pour
débuter ce journal 400000 400000 C3
Citroën produite à poiss par PSA l'usine
travaille sur ce modèle depuis 2009 elle
vient aussi de récupérer la production
d'oln sous bois après la fermeture du
site sur place à l'automne dernier le
secteur automobile qui a du mal à se
relever néanmoins l'URSAF a annoncé un
peu plus tôt dans cette semaine que les
constructeurs avaient vu leur effectif
chuté de 8,7 % en 1 an en 5 ans 10000
emplois perdus juste pour la région
francilienne mercredi 17 septembre un
rassemblement des 9500 notairire de
France est annoncé à Paris place de la
République la profession de dénonce un
projet de réforme qu' l'AVE et qui
permettrait notamment d'ouvrir les actes
de vente à d'autres professions le
gouvernement espère ainsi redonner du
pouvoir d'achat au français en faisant
chuter les tarifs des transactions c'est
l'effet inverse qui va se produire selon
les principaux intéressés Patrick JAC de
dixmud a rencontré l'un d'entre eux
aujourd'hui c'est comme si on disait
qu'un charcutier va pouvoir vous opérer
on va fermer toutes les études de France
le 17 le 17 septembre mercredi prochain
on va tous se retrouver place de la
République euh pour pour montrer notre
mécontentement et notre rassemblement
ferme par ailleurs toutes les
préfectures de France vont être vont
faire aussi l'objet de rassemblement par
tous les collaborateurs il y a peut-être
des choses à réformer on est
complètement ouvert au dialogue notre le
président du Conseil supérieur du
notariat monsieur tarad est ouvert au
dialogue je crois qu'il rencontre madame
tobira et Monsieur Macron la semaine
prochaine donc voilà il ser il
expliquera tout ça le Secours populaire
tire une nouvelle fois la sonnette
d'alarme la crise est bien installée
elle touche de plus en plus de personnes
nous sommes en ligne avec Pascal Rodier
le responsable départemental du Secours
populaire bonjour à vous Pascal Rodier
bonjour plusieurs indicateurs qui vous
inquiètent ce baromètre hipsos qui a été
publié jeudi 11 septembre et puis les
données collectées aussi dans vos
différentes permanences quels sont les
les enseignements en tirer quel est
l'état et quel est la situation de la en
matière de pauvreté en France
aujourd'hui bah la situation est un peu
concordante avec ce qui avait été publié
quelques jours avant sur l'enracinement
de la pauvreté malheureusement dans
notre pays euh donc c'est confirmé bah
malheureusement heureusement pass dire
comme ça pour pour qu'il se passe dans
nos permanences d'Acca ce que l'on
constate c'est que il y a une perfection
de des niveaux à partir desquels on par
la pauvreté qui tourne aux environs du
SMIC au niveau du montant donc ce qui
est tout même un peu préoccupant pour
quelques milons personnes dans notre
pays et on se retrouve en fait avec un
revenu disponible une fois qu'on a fait
face aux dépenses incompressibles que
peuvent être le logement et des
chararges àérent au logement sur des
montants qui dépassent à peine les 5 €
par jour donc quand on Fa pour manger à
peu près équilibré 2 à 3 € par jour et
par personne ça devient un défi vous
laisse imaginer ou on parle
effectivement d'un reste à vivre de 5,60
€ à peu près sur les personnes qui on
ont été consulté on imagine mal comment
vivre avec 5,60 € bah voilà comment
combien de personnes vous accueillez
dans dans vos antennes pour faire un
point par rapport au Département des des
ivelines est-ce que c'est en progression
cette année euh sur le département ça
évolue euh ça évolue tous les ans depuis
plusieurs années maintenant euh on a
dépassé les 1600 familles sur le
département de suivir régulièrement donc
principalement pour des aides
matérielles notamment alimentaire mais
pas que aussi pour les les départs en
vacances ou des formes de solidarité
donc oui ça ça progresse et en fait on
est aussi un petit peu plus pressé euh
par les par par les travailleurs sociaux
par le Conseil Général euh les par du
conseil général donc et puis en plus on
n'est pas tout seul c'est ça qui est
relativement que vous avez moins de
subventions c'est les problèmes que vous
rencontrez aussi en tout cas pas assez
pour répondre à toutes les demandes
alors
en fait on a un soutien du Conseil
général depuis la 2è c'est la 2è année
maintenant on a un soutien comme
d'autres associations qui à peu près le
même travail que nous qui s'élèv environ
environ à 35000 € par an pour vous
donner un ordre
d'idée avec 35000 € on va pas bien loin
est-ce que l'on
redistribue au niveau de la la
Fédération produits européenne
représente plus de 200000 € de valeur
marchandes donc 35000 € aide notre
réseau en fait à former les bénévoles
pour améliorer accueil donc c'est dans
ce sensl que le Conseil Général n nous
les n Les recroit ces subventions mais
35 paraître beaucoup pour un citoyen
l'ambas mais pour développer une aide
alimentaire régulière c'est relativement
peu puisque 1600 1700 familles ça fait
plus de 6000 personnes donc ça fait du
monde et on sent en tout cas en France
au-delà de situations de précarité qui
sont directement rencontrés par les
familles il y a aussi ce ce sentiment
cette inquiétude de basculer vers la la
misère 55 % des personnes le craignent
en tout cas c'est ce qui ressort de de
l'enquête ipso qui a été publiée hier
jeudi il y a ce sentiment d'insécurité
permanent concernant le la peur d'être
dans la misère c'est même pire que ça
puisque il y a plus d'un Français sur TR
qui déclare avoir déjà connu ou avoir
déjà été en situation de pauvreté donc
ça fait quand même plus de 20 million de
personnes donc bah c'est ça n'a échappé
à personne je pense
chez on est dans un contexte économique
d'emploi qui qui est compliqué et donc
pas non plus
l'optimisme de nos concitoyens et donc
c'est confirmé cont tenu du du niveau de
ressources nécessaire pour pouvoir un
peu dououcler boucl les fement quoi
merci Pascal Rudier d'avoir été en ligne
avec nous aujourd'hui vendredi pour
faire le point sur cette situation
actuellement je rappelle dans cette
étude hipsos Secours populaire qui fait
état de cette pauvreté qui progresse un
dernier chiffre pour 86 % des personnes
interrogées la peur que leur enfant soit
plus exposés à une situation de
précarité est plus que présente une
information à présent qui devrait
rassurer les utilisateurs de transport
en commun le 23 juillet le poste
d'éguillage de vitriille part tê en
fumée conséquence retard train bon pour
les voyageurs de la ligne C soit près
tout de même de 540000 usagers le
président de la SNCF Guillaume Pépi
vient d'annoncer que la procédure
d'appel d'offre pour le chantier de
reconstruction serait simplifié cela
permettrait de réduire les délais
jusqu'à présent il était question d'une
attente d'une trentaine de
mois comme chaque vendredi nous passons
maintenant à l'essentiel de cette
semaine et le nom très net des élus
locaux à une intercommunalité de 800000
habitants l'annonce d'une fusion de
plusieurs agglomérations par le préfet
de la région Île-de-France d'ici à 2015
avec la présentation d'une première
carte de travail a été l'occasion
d'échange vif entre les principaux
concernés pour notre secteur des
Yvelines Saint-Quentin Versailles mais
aussi une partie de l'esson pourit
fusionner Catherine
zulato une intercommunalité à 800000
habitants allant de plaisir Versailles
Grand Parc C50 an niveline jusqu'à
Massie trop grande pour le président de
la casquis cela n'a pas de sens c'est
une très mauvaise idée très mauvaise
idée de vouloir faire un territoire
aussi gigantesque je vous rappelle que
800000 habitants ça serait la plus
grosse intercommunaité de France comment
trouver une gouvernance équilibré d'un
territoire qui comprendrait des communes
comme la verrière des communes comme
orsé et on irait jusqu'à Vissou on
dirait jusqu'à Linas monlerie c'est
c'est complètement fou vous rappelle
quelques chiffres notre degré de
intercommunalité au niveau de sa-quentin
est de 50 % notre iné tion
intercommunale est de 50 % versaill
grandp est à 15 % la CAP c'est à peu
près pareil et EUR ne peut-être à 17 %
on regarde un petit peu la différence
qu'il y a le président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération rappelle qu'ils sont
membres du plateau de sa clé et il
estime que le travail commun est déjà
bien entamé la vraie réponse aujourd'hui
effectivement c'est de renforcer notre
coopération intercommunale avec d'autres
mais pour cela on n pas besoin de
fusionner toutes ces intercommunalités
même point de vue pour le président du
conseil général l'UMP pierre béer je
suis d'accord pour que on aille plus
loin que le simple établissement public
d'aménagement qui s'occupe du plateau de
saclé et donc je considère que les
quatre intercommunalités concernées
peuvent se réunir non pas fusionner mais
se réunir dans une structure qui n'est
pas une nouvelle hiérarchie
fonctionnaire impô et cetera mais qui
est un outil de coordination à gauche on
s'interroge également sur ce projet de
l'
intercommunalité le maire de La Verrière
souhaiterait plutôt valoriser l'existant
la proposition du préfet me semble pas
d'actualité en tout cas nous n'en sommes
certainement pas là aujourd'hui la
question c'est d'avoir un élargissement
tel que la loi nous y contraint un
élargissement et cet élargissement doit
se faire en fonction des projets
immédiats les élus de de gauche de
l'agglomération ont plaidé pour une une
intercommunalité qui s'élargit sur le
périmètre de l'O donc plutôt du côté sa
clé et l'intégration de morpas c'est une
position sur lequelle nous nous sommes
mis d'accord avec le maire de trappe le
maire de guillancour et le maire de BIS
c'est la position que nous défendons au
sein de l'agglomération du côté de
l'esson les dents grincent également ils
ne veulent pas notamment de la dette de
50 ans en Yveline les élus réunis au
sein de la commission régionale de
coopération intercommunale se serait
déjà prononcé contre ce rapprochement
d'ici 3 mois le préfet de région devrait
rendre son
arbitrage et au milieu de ce futur
mastodonte la petite commune de coignère
qui tient à son indépendance comme l'a
expliqué son maèire Henri paayux invité
du journal jeudi il est très en colère
il ne comprend pas pourquoi il devrait
quitter sa communauté de commune dè
étants qu'il a eu déjà beaucoup de mal à
accepter récemment on
l'écoute tout ça ce n'est que des
projets de technocrate en col blanc et
je les dénonce fortement et ce qui
m'atriste dans cette affaire c'est que
je découvre tout doucement que nos
parlementaires sont eux mêmes devenus
des technocrates je dénonce je DIRIS
tout ça et en plus de ça on nous
il faut savoir que plus les structures
sont grosses plus ça coûte cher le
résultat de tout ça c'est quoi et bien
c'est le fait que ce qui est en
perspective derrière parce que c'est la
logique du système c'est la disparition
des communes il faut le savoir ça alors
que les maires sont les élus les plus
appréciés de leur concitoyens parce que
ce sont des élus de proximité dans ma
communauté de commune des étants que
nous allons défendre parce qu'il faut
bien quand même qu'on défende quelque
chose et pour essayer d'aboutir à
quelque chose ayant une taille humaine
on va dire et bien il est parfaitement
clair que nos clochers sont à des
distances de 10 km les un par rapport
aux autres actuellement lorsqu'un
administré je dirais veut aller voir son
maire parce qu'il a des problèmes et
cetera c'est facile d'accès mais demain
il va falloir qu'il aille voir le
président de la comité de commune qui
est à 15 km de coière et après et après
la politique l'éducation toujours au
cœur de l'actualité en cette 2e semaine
de septembre les syndicats d'enseignants
premiers comme second degré viennent de
tenir une conférence de presse dans les
locaux de la FSU attrape il tirent la
sonnette d'alarmeux aussi sur le manque
de professeur une vraie crise du
recrutement qui touche actuellement le
pays 4h de philo au lycée d'hôellerie et
de tourisme de Guill en cour 8h de
technologie au lycée champolon à voisin
le Bretonneux pas de professeur
d'allemand au collège de la clé
Saint-Pierre à hencour 20h de
mathématiques non pourvu au lycée Émilie
de Breteuil à Montini voici quelques
exemples relevés par le Syndicat du
secondaire le SNES à à l'occasion de
cette rentrée 2014 des emplois ont
pourtant été créés les créations
d'emploi certes mais qui ne couvrent pas
les les ou à peine les hausses des
effectifs la deuxième problématique
c'est de pourvoir ses emplois étant
donné que on a de gros problèm de de
recrutement et donc rien que sur
l'académie de Versailles 300 postes
d'après le rectorat qui ne sont pas
pourvu suite au au au concours certaines
filières sont plus touchées que d'autres
comme les mathématiques la technologie
ou les sciences physiques mais une
situation que l'on retrouve aussi selon
les syndicats chez les professeurs de
sport et ça c'est nouveau on faisait
toujours le plein sur les concours et là
pour la première fois on n pas fait le
plein sur un concours et la liste
complémentaire qui a été ouverte la
première depuis de nombreuses années n'a
pas permis de faire le plein total ça se
voit pas directement dans les
établissements puisque il y a un volant
de de collègues qui sont chargés du
remplacement soit l'année soit de sur
les courtes et moyennes durées et qui
permettent de de boucher les trous une
des raisons qui pourrait expliquer ce
manque d'envie l'image du métier et le
salaire un jeune professeur des écoles
démarre à
1,17 fois le SMIC pour un niveau d'étude
à à Master 1 puisque ils sont recrutés
le concours a lieu au master 1 et
peut-être que ça ne suscite plus de
vocation pour l'heure donc les volants
horaires manquants sont comblés par des
heures supplémentaires et des
contractuelles devraient être recruté
par le rectorat les syndicats restent
attentifs cette question ainsi que celle
des rythmes scolaires devrait être à
l'ordre du jour du prochain comité
technique prévu fin
septembre éducation toujours un Institut
d'études politiques en France dans les
ivelines c'est même une première cela
faisait 20 ans à travers le pays
qu'aucune création n'avait été possible
sciencep Saint-Germain onl vient
d'ouvrir ses portes à 80 étudiants cette
semaine ces premiers pas sont en quelque
sorte historiques ces étudiants sont les
premiers de l'Institut d'études
politiques de Saint-Germain en la mais
la particularité de ce 10e IEP est
ailleurs ses liens avec ses deux faculté
fondatrice serg Pontoise et l'université
de Versailles 550 ans en Yveline dont 40
% des enseignants sont issus l'objectif
créer à terme des passerelles entre les
établissements d'une part on met en
place des dispositifs de préparation au
concours dans les lycées publics et à
l'université et puis il est prévu en
2016 l'ouvert d'un concours 4e année qui
sera spécifique puisque on ouvrira des
places par section et qui seront ouverts
aux étudiants des universités donc les
pasastrelles oui on les crée cette
première promotion de l'ieep ivelinois
se compose de 82 étudiants pour 41
professeurs ils bénéficieront d'une
formation sur 5 ans dont la dernière
dans un des Master 2 de l'UVSQ ou de
sergie Pontoise et si les plus
pessimistes tendent à penser que cette
première promotion va essuyer les plates
du côté des élèves participer à cette
aventure est une vraie chance d'être la
première promo c'est vrai que on insiste
bien la directrice a bien insisté sur le
fait que c'est nous qui allons marquer
un peu l'image de l'EP et C
donc ouais on est tous content de
pouvoir créer plein de choses aussi vu
que tout est à faire genre de pouvoir
faire nos associations nos trucs à la
fin de leur cursus ils seront alors
titulaires d'un double diplôme de l'EP
et de leur université de rattachement
pour peut-être devenir les chefs
d'entreprise de
demain c'est l'événement culturel de ce
début d'automne 24 24 pour 24 heur de
spectacle de danse de concert le
vélodrome de Montini le Bretonneux s'est
associé avec Juste Debout déjà à
l'origine de l'un des plus grands
festival de danse hip hop et qui déplace
pour son étape parisienne à Bery plus de
15000 personnes depuis une dizaine
d'années 24 va regrouper des artistes
internationaux le 27 septembre
l'organisation se met en place comme
nous l'ont expliqué les principaux
concernés ils étaient sur ce plateau
mardi soir je suis avide de travail donc
j'aime j'aime le travail j'aime me
mettre des problèmes parce que quand on
fait de la production on fait on a
beaucoup de problèmes sur sur les
épaules mais c'est avant tout pour pour
un peu se diversifier c'est vrai qu'on a
fait on a fait un festival qui s'appelle
Juste Debout qui réunit des danseurs
mais maintenant on voulait encore
étendre la chose et par parler à tout le
monde avec du rap de la danse du yoga ça
va aller a-delà de la danse al que juste
debout c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
spécifique sur la danse de s'installer
au Vélodrome ça sera le premier
rendez-vous culturel on va venir en plus
sur ce site c'est une très belle salle
je connais brus depuis des années on
s'est dit pourquoi pas faire un truc
ensemble là-bas et puis il m'a montré la
salle et j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai adoré donc
voilà c'est avant tout c'est une
histoire de de cœur c'est pas c'est pas
seulement un one shot
c'est la longévité danse concert comment
ça va s'organiser un peu cette journée
ttif for 24 24 artistes 24h ça débute à
14h jusqu'au 14h le lendemain c'est quoi
un petit peu l'organisation de la
journée déjà on sera plus de 24
personnes pour pour la préparation et
l'organisation ça c'est ça c'est certain
euh ça va ça va s'orenter de manière
assez simple on va avoir des des équipes
de bénévoles assez spécialisé donc on va
prendre des bénévoles de la localité
mais aussi de du Juste Debout pour avoir
pour avoir leur expertise forcément
l'équipe vélopolis également qui est la
société d'exploitation de du véodrome
National donc on sera tous sur le le
pied de guerre pour pour que bah pour
que tout ça aboutisse correctement et
puis il y a le junior Nour on n'a pas
oublié les les enfants euh c'est de
c'est un battle qui qui qui prend les
enfants de 8 ans à 15 ans et donc c'est
pour les voilà pour dynamiser un peu
tout le monde quoi aussi bien les
parents les enfants tout ça combien de
personnes attendu sur le festival un
objectif de 6000 personnes et
l'intégralité de cette interview est à
retrouver sur notre site Internet pour
ceux qui ne seront pas présents le 27
septembre à Montini TVfil vous proposera
en tout cas le premier octobre une
édition spéciale de kiosk pour découvrir
les meilleurs moments et d'ici là autre
rendez-vous spécial sur TV f lundi 18h
avec un journal consacré en grande
partie au 30 ans de Black blomber la
compagnie pionnière en danse Hipop le 15
septembre 84 elle donnait son tout
premier spectacle dans un parking
souterrain à Montini le Bretonneux entre
la National 10 et la gare nous vous
proposons de revenir avec quelques
danseurs qui seront présents sur place
voici déjà un extrait de cette interview
à découvrir lundi donc déjà en rentrant
dans le parking j'ai eu des frisson donc
beaucoup de souvenirs moi pour moi c'est
la jeunèse c'est vraiment la jeunèse
avec blamber tout a commencé ici quoi
dans ce parking pour vous c'est pareil
des frissons en arrivant un peu sur ce
lieu voilà ça réactive plein plein plein
de souvenirs des émotions fortes et ben
sur les et la danse qui
transpirait dans dans tous ces états
voilà il y a pas de de vidéo qui reste
de ce spectacle malheureusement vous
n'avez pas fait de captation à l'époque
mais ça se passait comment il y avait 40
danseurs ici il faut imaginer alors
c'était pas tout à fait à cet étage du
parking mais il y avait 40 danseurs oui
y avait 40 40 danseurs il y
avait une dizaine de techniciens il y
avait
musiciens et puis il y avait tout le
personnel de la pasque à l'époque la
Maison pour tous parce que c'est quand
même une opération très lourde qui a été
portée par l'ensemble de l'institution
et donc il fallait transformer ce lieu
en lieu de spectacle et en même temps
lui garder sa valeur objective de
parking de lieu urbain avec un lieu de
vie peut-être qu'on l'a entendu passer
il y a le train aussi il fallait
composer avec tous les éléments
extérieurs ouais mais c'était bien des
fois le train parce que le début du
spectacle c'était sur un un saxo et
c'était Richard R qui qui faisait
l'entrée et à chaque fois le boogie
collait bien quoi avec le passage du
train tout ça ça ça c'était un son de
ville qui de bonne qualité ouais édition
spéciale du journal de la rédaction
lundi des 18h pour revenir sur les 30
ans du tout premier spectacle de la
compagnie black blomber compagnie qui a
vu le jour donc à Saint-Quentin en
Yveline on en revient pour l'instant à
l'actualité du jour je vous rappelle
cette information les notaires ont
annoncé mercredi 17 septembre qu'ils se
rassembleront à Paris place de la
République 9500 notire de France sont
attendus la profession qui dénonce un
projet de réforme qui la vise et qui
permettrait notamment d'ouvrir les actes
de vente à d'autres professions le
gouvernement qui espère ainsi redonner
du pouvoir d'achat aux Français en
faisant chuter les tarif des
transactions c'est l'effet inverse qui
va se produire selon les principaux
intéressés qui s'expliquent aujourd'hui
c'est comme si on disait qu'un
charcutier va pouvoir vous opérer on va
fermer toutes les études de France le 17
le 17 septembre mercredi prochain on va
tous se retrouver place de la République
euh pour montrer notre mécontentement et
notre rassemblement ferme
euh par ailleurs toutes les préfectures
de France vont être vont faire aussi
l'objet de rassemblement par tous les
collaborateurs il y a peut-être des
choses à à réformer on est complètement
ouvert au dialogue notre le président du
Conseil supérieur du notariat monsieur
tarad est ouvert au dialogue je crois
qu'il rencontre madame tobira et
Monsieur Macron euh la semaine prochaine
euh donc voilà il sera il expliquera
tout ça fin du journal on se retrouve
donc lundi à 18h pour vous accompagner
d'ici là Antony reche avec le 78 weekend
pour un point sur vos loisirs et vos
sorties à
lundi